yes indeed welcome Fabiano coron is here
with us in the studio the game with
Maxim R gr just finished in a draw uh
not
surprisingly for for this tournament so
far so how would you assess your
participation at the moment in this
event yeah it's a bit of a strange
tournament I missed a huge chance
yesterday completely winning uh during
the game I started to feel absolutely
exhausted for some reason like I
couldn't calculate a single move and I
was trying to sit there trying to
calculate and then I got low on time
and uh yeah that yesterday was a big
Miss today I think was a very stable
game how was it to play Thanksgiving by
the way Happy Thanksgiving Happy
Thanksgiving yeah that's uh well you
know we've as chess players we play
during all sorts of days and I've played
on my birthday and all during you know
Christmas as well and all sorts of
occasions so it's not too unusual and I
think tonight will be a nice
celebration um yeah but at least I
didn't lose that that's that's the main
thing yeah that's important yes game I
think also it's important it was an
important game yes by the way the game
between Richard Robert and ala just
finished in the draw yes after
repetition so sorry for this break let's
let's come back to this one I think it
was also important for the standings and
for overall standings of gr have you
thought about it a little bit not too
much it's again very
unusual a player withdrew well out of
necessity young Kristoff got ill in some
way so hopefully he recovers but again
very unusual yet so like like last year
we're missing a player from the
tournament so it's for me it's a bit of
a strange situation because I'm going to
have three blacks in a row yeah um which
okay I I guess it's not the biggest deal
but uh it's very unfortunate of course
for the tournament and also I feel bad
for for young Kristoff because it's um
yeah it's always unpleasant to come all
this way and you know you get ill or or
something like that and you can't play
anymore so so that's quite unfortunate
yeah it's affected also your situation I
think now there are no chances that you
will end up in the last place I'm sorry
to say so I don't think it was the case
but I mean um worst case scenarios are
not possible anymore yeah yeah that's
true um but I anyway I'm hoping not to
have a bad tournament so we'll see so
far everyone's having the same
tournament maybe maybe we'll be one big
happy family at uh at the end of the
tournament caring first through last
place you know this possible yes it's
probably not going to happen but I think
today we played a correct game like I I
don't think anything happened that was
special it was a bit sharp um but okay I
think this is kind of known Theory um it
was played in Rapid and Blitz they
mentioned game actually was played kuang
and and Ali Resa play the game mhm but I
think that Maxi made it interesting at
this moment because I think that the
game between Ali Resa and laang laang
was white was like was like this
something like this basically I forget
exactly which uh version they got this
end game in but it was this end game
which is equal and Max te made it
interesting with this move uh leads
Again by force to to this situation with
uh with like two pieces versus rook and
and versus Rook yeah I get the pawn by
force quite important mhm
and I I think it's kind of forcing
because like he doesn't want to get this
kind of situation where if I put my Rook
on C2 he's suddenly stuck he can't move
his pieces and also Bishop C1 I can take
on F2 but also I have this move Rook C2
I wasn't 100% sure but I calculated some
lines where I'm you know grabbing this
pawn and then very often I also grab
this Pawn where I play like C5 here and
my a pawn becomes very fast but also I
thought I can take enough too when did
you get this ending what was your
feeling like
you were a bit shocked or it was kind of
normal no well I kind of knew that it's
possible and I didn't know the details
but I figured that it's equal and it was
easy to figure out the lines like I was
calculating various moves here of course
white
has actually there was like an option to
play Rook C2 I think but then this was
kind of important I think that Bishop B4
Rook
B2 then suddenly he has his Knight D3
this is very unpleasant and then he gets
this one and he attacks C7 as well so I
take here and yeah I was looking at some
various moves here like Knight D7 trying
to get to C5 um but always I can attack
his pawns like Knight D7 Rook C2 um or
or even Rook A2 very often is coming and
uh and then yeah if The Bishop's on B4 I
have A5 and okay I wasn't surprised by
this but this leads to a foreen sequence
because I liquidate some pawns so here
it's clear that black cannot really risk
too much here because it's only one Pawn
left and for him to capture this Pawn
there's only one way he has to put the
bishop on A5 and Knight on C5 cuz if he
puts Knight on B8 like let's say here he
plays Knight D7 F5 KN B8 then he gets in
trouble with with A4 A5 sorry I guess
it's not real trouble but I thought okay
maybe my Pawn runs to A4 or maybe I can
just trade pawns with the draw mhm so
there's so he needs to put the bishop on
A5 in order to do it to block the pawn
right yeah there's no other way like
also Knight C6 I can I can move my king
like King H7 I thought and again Knight
the A5 so so he put the bishop there I
was kind of expecting Knight D7 first
but I don't know if it makes a
difference okay here I was like looking
at various moves they all looked like
kromy um like I thought F4 first but
then I thought maybe H4 I don't know
maybe H4 like if GH4 then suddenly gets
the Stable Square for his Knight which
of course is also a draw um and if King
G7 I thought maybe H5 the KN on G4 okay
I didn't anyway with the KN on G4 he
can't move but I was like trying to be
super super accurate I played Rook C2 so
now H4 I just Advanced my king there's
no point and okay he went here here King
G1 because I'm threatening F3 and we
just repeated moves I was thinking some
time about H5
here with the point that okay Knight C5
then G4 take take Knight A6 G3 anyway
King F1 I didn't see a way forward but
at least here like he has to maybe if
you go to Gan King F3 yes yeah yeah and
then he goes to to like uh G4 for
example okay here I actually don't want
to do this because now I'm the one who
has to prove the draw but then I was
thinking well yeah I play H5 and he
plays King F1 so G4 is not possible so I
play like King
F7 Knight C5 G4 take take again Knight
A6 G3 but then I thought Knight D3 and I
was like maybe I'm losing my F Pawn like
G3 Bishop B6 so he has threats Knight F4
and I thought anyway like worst case
this
position like everything is a draw at
this moment because okay he's left with
one Pawn but why should I do this so I I
just played Rook C1 King F2 and
just yes of course I mean it's also
Thanksgiving today um I was wondering if
you saw this tweet from Magnus yesterday
that he was celebrating like 10
anniversary of winning the world
championship title and he also published
this photo where he jumped inside of the
swimming pool fully I mean with his
clothes on and so Fabby at the moment
when you become the world champion what
are you going to do what is the craziest
thing you are you will do let's agree
from now oh wow the craziest thing I
don't know I can't uh I can't say yet I
think this has to be spontaneous right
yes maybe but but um if if I I don't
think it's like when because I think
it's more if but if I become world
champion someday then uh then definitely
I'll do something crazy but I'm not sure
yet let's keep it spontaneous exactly
yes okay I hope I'll will be invited to
take some photos
of course of course I agreed it will be
some uh well we don't know what it will
be but no I thought that um yeah Magnus
had a good celebration of course in 2013
I think there was also some people who
like when it was Winter uh let's say
invite gen MH if they won the tournament
they would like jump into the North Sea
yeah yeah I remember such bets yes yeah
uh so this is kind of crazy I mean you
know you don't want to like win a
tournament and then you get carried out
into the North and nobody ever sees you
again so maybe there's some like safer
sa to celebrate yeah yeah Magnus did it
by jumping in the uh in the fountain
right this is a bit safer yes yes yes
for sure I mean you'll have the
candidates on April yes in Canada so
maybe we can also discuss this but okay
let let me give you the chance to
celebrate properly Thanksgiving thank
you so much fa for the interview and all
the best in the next rounds than thank
you uh Anastasia and because it's
Thanksgiving let's wind it up Peter